[Música]
gracias por continuar con nosotros y
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia doctor bienvenido
de lado ms eleva a 4 millones la cifra
del personal sanitario en el mundo
contagiado de ccoo y 19 de los casi 30
millones de casos confirmados es decir
el 14 por ciento de los casos globales
un sector fuertemente golpeado por la
pandemia él le pregunto cómo es la
situación para ellos en américa latina'
sumado al que estamos más expuestos al
virus tenemos un problema de desigualdad
por ejemplo en cuanto salarial esta
línea laboral en las circunstancias
donde se trabajan en grandes ciudades
puede ser más cómoda en la práctica
privada por una parte pública regional
tiene muchas más limitaciones en cuanto
a materiales de protección elementos
para trabajo y eso hace que la situación
de esa desigualdad sea tan marcada en
américa latina si ha afectado la
población de europa mucho más a nuestras
poblaciones y nuestra región ahora la
oms se ha dicho también que uno de cada
cuatro profesionales de la salud dice
haber sufrido ansiedad o depresión
durante esta pandemia y uno de cada tres
padeció insomnio usted que trabaja en
una unidad de cuidados intensivos en la
primera línea de batalla que nos puede
decir de la salud mental del gremio
médico
no yo creo que somos todos los que hemos
afectados no es una tercera tal vez una
tercera parte de lo manifiesta no lo
hacen clínica pero todos hemos sufrido
mucho ante la incapacidad del desespero
por querer hacer las cosas mejor y a
veces por no poder lograr el éxito que
uno quisiera sin embargo también hemos
creado unas cadenas de confianza y
grandes equipos humanos y hemos
aprendido a reconfortarnos en medio de
la tristeza es la hora de llamar la
atención hacia la salida del grupo
médico al grupo de enfermería esperarte
son muchas las planas que está en el
hospital de una forma valiente y hay que
acompañarlos en este momento todos hemos
sufrido alguna forma el impacto de esta
pandemia ahora autor bajo este panorama
hay escasez de empleados en el sector le
pregunto no sólo por los que han se han
contagiado sino también por lo que por
los que han renunciado por falta de
garantías en la región como el caso que
se está viendo en ecuador
y es la suma de la exposición la
enfermedad
la limitación y bajos salarios en
estabilidad laboral no podemos esperar
más de una persona que trabaja como
enfermera como terapista que recibe una
remuneración poca para su esfuerzo pero
además de eso no le pagan por ejemplo y
se está exponiendo todos los días entre
hace un balance limpio beneficios no
pues prefiero quedar mi casa a buscar
otro trabajo o hacer alguna atención
ambulatoria y eso es lo que está pasando
no solamente hacemos nos hemos enfermado
sino muchos se han retirado a hacer
otras labores básicamente porque no hay
sostenible el sistema tiene que haber
justicia laboral acompañamiento y mejor
remuneración en cuanto a los salarios
entonces usted afirma que no se han
mantenido durante esta pandemia que
pareciera a lo mejor ser lo contrario
pareciera que probablemente los médicos
puedan ganar más ante esta situación
pero lamentablemente la realidad es
totalmente distinta
completamente distinta aquí todos
perdemos y nadie se está enriqueciendo
ni nadie está ganando más estamos
agotados de trabajar muchas más horas de
las que nos piden y aquí el problema no
es la remuneración aquí el problema es
la estabilidad nosotros tenemos un
trabajo de alto riesgo necesitamos
estabilidad necesitamos un tratamiento
justo no más que cualquier otro empleado
simplemente justicia y acompañamiento y
estabilidad ahora estamos viendo un poco
de relajación en la región por parte de
los gobiernos en cuanto al confinamiento
ante la posibilidad de los rebrotes en
la región está preparado el personal de
salud y las instituciones para esta
situación
todo este tiempo debía ser para
prepararnos para afrontar lo mejor para
haber fortalecido los sistemas de salud
la esperanza es que los gobiernos tomen
esta primer enseñanza para poder
fortalecer fortalecer sus equipos de
salud esto no es con vídeos de ánimo
esto es con hechos reales
ojalá que en la región se fortalezca el
personal sanitario con tratamiento como
lo repito justo estabilidad no más allá
de cualquier trabajador pero sí en la
dimensión de una persona que está
enfrentando una pandemia nuestra
situación de rebrotes puede ser compleja
básicamente por la ausencia de personal
sanitario más que por la preparación de
este personal así es doctor pues
esperamos lo mejor entonces para nuestra
región y también para el personal de
salud que al final de cuentas son los
que luchan y nos ayudan a combatir esta
pandemia de coronavirus gracias doctor
por la información usted está bien
gracias por estar con nosotros en france
[Música]